>> Nicole Chung: Good afternoon.
I'm Nicole Chung with the
"Washington Post" Book World,
and the "Washington Post"
is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First a word of thanks to the
co-chairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein and other
generous sponsors who've made
this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
please note the information
in your program.
We'll have some time after this
presentation for your questions,
and I've been asked to
remind you that if you come
to the microphone, you'll
be included in the videotape
of this event which may be
broadcast at a later date.
Our guest this afternoon
is Ms Jennifer Nielsen
who is an amazing
lovely wonderful author
who writes primarily
young adult fantasy
and historical fiction novels.
Her most recent series,
"The Traitor's Game,"
and her other series include
the Ascendance trilogy,
the "Mark of the Thief" series,
and her historical
fiction "Resistance."
Without much further
ado, Jennifer Nielsen.
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
All right.
How is everybody today?
If you're enjoying the
festival, then yeah.
This is incredible.
Thank you for being here.
I am here too.
My name is Jennifer Nielsen.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about --
These are some of the books
that I've done, but I'm going
to talk specifically
about "Resistance" here.
This is my newest book.
It's also here, but
that's bigger.
So for "Resistance" let me start
with where I discovered
this story.
A couple of years ago I
took a trip to Poland,
and we visited the Jewish
cemetery which is here.
The Jewish cemetery
was a very profound,
very sacred feeling sort
of space, but there was one
of the gravestones in
particular that caught my eye.
It was this one.
Now as you look at it
carefully, you're going to see
that one thing is
different from the others.
Do you see it?
Let me point it out.
Right here.
All right?
Do you see a different
death date there?
Rafael Goldberg [assumed
spelling] went by the name
of Eugenis [assumed spelling]
[inaudible] which I'm going
to slaughter the pronunciation.
I'm very sorry.
He was the oldest
child in the family.
Rafael was Jewish, but
forged papers to pass
as a Polish Christian in
order to survive the war.
He was the only survivor
of his family.
And this gravestone
captured my attention
so much it simply just
ignited this curiosity in me
to know more about someone
who would be the one
to change his name, and
pass as a Polish citizen.
But it didn't end there.
We went on a tour of
Krakow in the ghetto.
And I found this picture.
This is not cropped in.
This is the actual picture I
took which was a huge mistake.
And it talks about the
underground theaters.
I'm a theater major so I
thought I wanted to know more
about these underground
theaters.
So I snapped the photo for
the only reason to go home
and research it later.
That was the mistake.
I went home.
I could not find
one single thing
about the underground theaters.
And the more I searched,
so I would search terms
as Polish underground,
Jewish underground,
Jewish underground Krakow,
and then I found my story.
In doing the research for
"Resistance" it started
with me reading as many books
as I could get my hands on,
reading websites,
watching videos,
looking at interviews
and diaries.
And I came up with this.
Just pages.
I have 60 pages just of notes.
Not the printouts.
Just notes.
And I thought there's
no way I can compile all
of that information.
So I thought, "I'm going
to make a timeline."
So on the wall of my office you
see these six poster boards.
They're color coded because
it turns out I'm super OCD.
Didn't know that.
But I started color coding
these just to give me a timeline
of the highlights of the event.
And that wasn't enough because
I was missing one thing.
And the thing I was missing,
these were the dates.
These were the facts.
It wasn't the people.
I needed the people.
This poster board
sits very closest
to where I would do my writing.
These are the faces or those
who actually did the thing
that I am writing about.
These are the true heroes
of the Jewish resistance
movement in Krakow, Poland.
So let me tell you the story
of the resistance
movement of Krakow, Poland.
This is the history of the war.
We have Poland.
When the Germans invaded,
that was September 1, 1939.
That was the start of the war.
Germany floods across the
border in a blitzkrieg.
It was an attack so massive that
the country of Poland collapsed.
In 25 days, they
had surrendered.
When the Germans moved
in, they said, "All right.
Warsaw is the traditional
capital, but not for us.
We're going to make
Krakow the capital
of the general government."
So to the Nazi empire
it will be Krakow.
Because Krakow was the new
capital, they didn't want
as many Jewish people in it.
So they said, "15,000
can remain,
and the rest have to leave."
So who are you going
to keep in Krakow?
Well, you can keep your
adults, and the children
who are dependent upon them.
There was one demographic
you didn't need there.
Your teenagers.
Teenagers largely
were sent away.
Now these teenagers
who were sent away,
they'd never lived on their own.
They were city kids
all of a sudden thrust
in to the Polish countryside.
But these were kids who --
It wasn't just a
Polish countryside.
It was full of Nazis,
and Polish citizens
who were not sympathetic
to them.
And these kids thought,
"Where will we go?"
Well, they remembered,
"We have scout leaders."
In the Jewish organizations
the scout was
for the boys and the girls.
And they remembered, "We
have these scout leaders,
the Draengers [assumed
spelling].
Shimshon Draenger [assumed
spelling] is a newspaper editor.
He's 21 years old.
His wife, Gusta,
is 20 years old.
She's a housewife.
And one by one these teenagers
show up at their home,
and they say, "Can we
come in to your farm?"
And the Draengers said, "Yes.
Of course."
For a while, the Draengers
were isolated from the war
with the teenagers there,
but bit by bit they started
hearing what's happening
to their families
back in the ghettos.
They hear about the actions.
They hear about the deportments.
They hear about the
lineups in the streets.
And these teenagers realize
that they have to make a choice.
Choice number one.
They do nothing.
If they do nothing,
it is only a matter
of time before they will die
on their knees to the Nazis.
Choice number two.
They will almost
certainly die as well,
but they will die fighting back.
In actual history one night
these teenagers sat around,
and the Draengers
called for a vote.
Who is in?
And, one by one, these
teenagers' hands went up.
Now one of the jobs they
needed these teenagers
to do was the job of a courier.
The job of a courier was
to go to the ghetto gates.
The ghettos were sealed.
No Jewish people in or out.
And so it was a way
of isolating them.
They needed a teenager to
go to the ghetto gates,
look that Nazi officer
in the eye,
and convince him
that she is Jewish.
On her back she is
smuggling food,
information, money, and weapons.
She knows it is likely that
one day she will be caught,
and if she is, she has
sworn never to give
up any information
about the resistance.
Who are you going
to use to do that?
No males. Because of
circumcision, you cannot do it.
No mothers.
They have children or
they have work duty.
It only gives you
one demographic,
and that was your teenage girls.
In actual history, girls
15, 16, 17 years old,
that is what they would
do, face that Nazi officer,
talk her way inside the ghetto.
Once she gets inside,
it is her job
to convince the Jewish
people she is one of them
because most likely she
will be smuggling someone
out to a safe house.
This resistance movement
that grew from the couriers
in Krakow was known as Akiba,
named after a Jewish
rabbi from biblical times.
And Akiba conducted a raid
that was all across Krakow.
As a result of the
raid, the Draengers --
Shimshon was arrested.
His wife gave herself up.
That was a pact they had made.
Whatever happens to one of us,
the other of us will follow.
The Draengers were sent
to Montelupich prison.
Montelupich was the
worst of the worst.
The Nazis started
with her, with Gusta.
And this is why it's important.
This book right here is -- It
is called "Justyna's Narrative."
Justyna is Gusta's code name.
That's the name she went by.
This book isn't in
print anymore.
If you were to see this
in a used bookstore,
most likely you'd pass this up.
Nothing interesting about this.
I'm going to tell you about this
book's importance in history.
The Nazis started with Gusta.
They absolutely tortured her.
And when they had done it,
and Gusta refused to give
up a single word
about the resistance,
then they bring her husband in.
They brought Shimshon in.
Now those of you
who are husbands,
or if you have a
husband, you know how far
that man will go to
protect his wife.
And he comes in, and he sees
what the Nazis have done to her.
And he's ready to do whatever
he needs to save his wife,
but Gusta looks at her husband
and she says, "Look at this.
They did their worst
to me, and I'm fine.
Don't tell them anything."
And she is the one who upholds
the secret of the resistance.
They take her back to her
cell in Montelupich prison.
There's other women there also
from Akiba who were arrested.
Gusta, they'd broken
the bones of her hands.
So she cannot write.
But she starts to
dictate her story.
Five women are taking
the dictation.
They're writing it down
on strips of toilet paper.
They sew the strips of
toilet paper together
with a thread from
their dresses.
They had one needle in the
cell, and they would share it
to sew these toilet
paper pieces together.
They then smuggled
out as much --
They smuggled out
all five copies,
hoping that at least something
would safely get through.
This book is what
Gusta Draenger narrated
from Montelupich prison.
We have all but one
and a half chapters
of her record of
this resistance.
This is the reason we
know it even existed.
This is the only reason we
know what these teenagers
accomplished here is
because of Gusta Draenger.
Now in this book, in
"Resistance," I'm going
to follow two Jewish
couriers from Krakow ghettos.
I'm going to follow them up to
Lodz [assumed spelling] ghetto
in the center of Poland.
Lodz was the worst of
the worst of the ghettos.
It was a horrible,
horrible place.
And then by spring
of 1943 I'm going
to bring these two
couriers in to Warsaw.
Warsaw ghetto was the
largest of the ghettos.
In January of 1943, the Nazis
entered with a plan to remove
as many as 300,000 Jewish
people in to the death camps.
The Jewish people fought back.
And, in fact, chased the
Nazis out of the ghettos.
But they knew it was
only a matter of time
that the Nazis would come back.
And, when they came back,
they would come back in force.
So they began to prepare.
By spring of 1943, this man, his
name is Mordechai Anielewicz.
He was 21 years old at
the beginning of the war.
He was a career counselor.
No military background.
This man organized Jewish
civilians in an uprising
against the Nazi army.
On the night before Passover,
an announcement went throughout
the Jewish population trapped
inside the ghetto, and it said,
"The Nazis have our
ghetto surrounded."
And on Passover morning
it would begin.
Mordechai Anielewicz would
lead Jewish civilians,
about 450 of them, against
the entire Nazi army.
This is a picture of one
of the Jewish fighters
from the rooftops.
They survived longer
against the Nazi army
than the entire country of
Poland lasted against the Nazis.
It was always clear how
the story was going to end,
but for the Jewish people,
this was their victory
because in this moment
they said,
"It doesn't matter
what our end is.
It matters that we
chose our end.
We chose this.
And we did not go
down on our knees."
The theme of resistance
is best stated this way.
This comes from the
afterward of the book.
It says, "May we never forget.
May we live with
honor at all times,
regardless of our circumstances.
And may we choose love, a weapon
that will defeat hate
every single time
because love is the resistance."
This book deals with what
the Nazis decided to do
about the so-called
Jewish problem.
And we live in a world right now
where you can see the recyclings
of hate and anger and name
calling and isolation.
And if we respond to that
with hate, and anger,
and name calling, and isolation,
we are feeding in
to the problem.
If we wish to be a solution,
the resistance is love.
I've got some time, I believe,
to take any questions about any
of my books or Holocaust
related questions
or about "Resistance"
specifically
if someone has a question.
Wonderful.
You stepped right up.
Excellent.
Yes.
>> Speaker 1: Yes.
Okay. Sorry.
I read your book
"The Night Divided."
>> Jennifer A Nielsen: Yes.
>> Speaker 1: What
was your inspiration
for the main character's friend?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen: Oh.
Okay. So "Night Divided"
is the --
is a Berlin Wall escape story.
The main character is Gerta.
Her friend is Anna.
To understand Anna, you have
to understand what East
Germany was like in 1964.
This is the best way
to understand it.
At the height of its
power, the secret police
and the Soviet Union,
that was the KGB,
they had one secret agent
for every 5,600 citizens.
So every 5,600 people,
1 secret police.
At the height of the
power for the Gestapo.
That's the secret
police of the Nazis.
1 secret policeman
for 2,000 citizens.
In 1964 the secret
police were the Stasi.
They had 1 secret police
for every 166 individuals.
But that wasn't good
enough for them.
Every apartment building
has a spy.
Your bus driver was
probably a spy.
Your postman was a spy.
Your teacher was a spy.
And then Anna, her best friend
in the story, became recruited.
Right? If you take the total
number of spies and informants
that the Stasi used, the number
went to 1 in 12 which means,
in this room, every
section of the carpet,
every row in this
room, at least 1 person
on that row would be
here to spy on you.
Anna is there as a best friend
because she was positively
representing that part
of East Germany which
means trust no one
because you could
not trust anyone.
That was an awesome question.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 2: So my school is
doing a battle of the books,
and your book "False
Prince" is in it.
And I was wondering what
gave you the inspiration
for "False Prince."
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
For "False Prince."
Thank you.
"False Prince" is the
story of a boy who's forced
to impersonate royalty, and he
wants nothing to do with it.
But if he doesn't, he's
going to be killed.
And so there's very high stakes.
I knew I wanted to write a
story about someone being forced
to impersonate a prince.
I didn't have Sage.
Sage was found in a song by
a guy named Eddie Vedder.
Any Pearl Jam fans
in the audience?
Yes. Absolutely.
The lead singer of the Pearl
Jam group is Eddie Vedder.
He did a solo album.
One song was called
"Guaranteed."
This is the line of the song.
"I knew all the rules, but
the rules did not know me."
Sound like Sage?
I found Sage in the song,
and once I had Sage,
I had the whole story.
So it came from a song.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 3: How did
you decide to make "Mark
of the Thief" take
place in Rome?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
"Mark of the Thief" always.
"Mark of the Thief" is
ancient Rome with magic.
It always had to take place.
And it's because of
two facts I knew.
Number one.
That every Roman child who was a
citizen would have worn a bulla,
that amulet.
And I just thought
that was kind of cool,
but I knew fact number
two, that Julius Caesar
in actual history used to
tell the people he had come
from the gods.
So he would be like, "Oh,
Venus, that you all worship?
Yeah. That's my grandma."
Right? And I thought, "Well,
what if Caesar was
telling the truth?"
If he really had
come from the gods,
Julius Caesar would
have been a demigod.
And what if his magic was kept
in his bulla that becomes lost
after his death and
remains lost for 200 years?
So it always had
to be ancient Rome
because of Caesar and the bulla.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 4: In
the "Runaway King,"
what was your inspiration
for Harlowe?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen: Okay.
In the "False Prince"
series Sage is trying
to rebuild a family.
Correct? He needed a dad figure.
And Mott kind of plays the
dad figure, but not enough
because Mott's more like
an older brother to him.
He needed a dad, and
he needed a dad figure
who would love him despite
how difficult he is,
and troublesome he is.
And so Harlowe became that
person who would just love him.
I love Harlowe.
Thank you.
>> Speaker 5: You've
written a lot
of Holocaust books,
like themed books.
So I was wondering what
inspired you to write all
of those Holocaust themed books.
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
Do you know,
for Holocaust I've written
two of the German books.
This is the first Holocaust.
>> Speaker 5: Well, like
the German and the --
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
The Germans, certainly.
I don't know.
Germany calls me.
It calls me from both ends.
What Germany has done right
in the world, and mistakes
that Germany has
made in the world,
which they fully acknowledge.
There's a piece of my heart
that belongs there,
and I don't know why.
It just does.
But thank you.
Thank you for asking.
>> Speaker 6: Why do you write
books about European history?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
You know what?
I don't search for European
history for my books.
For an author, stories
will come to you.
All right?
I don't necessarily
go looking for them.
But I know.
And I -- Do you ever
write stories?
All right.
Do you ever get an idea,
and all of a sudden it feels
like there's magic in your head?
You know what I'm talking about?
I look for that magic
in my head,
and then I know that's
the story I have to write.
I would never limit myself
and say I can't write
about this part of the world.
I just look for when
I feel magic
in my head, and I
start to write.
Same as you.
Wonderful.
>> Speaker 7: Which
characters do you
like in your books
that you wrote?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
I need help with that
question one more time.
>> Speaker 7: Which books --
I mean which books do
have the characters
that you [inaudible]
in your books?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen: Which --
>> Speaker 8: Characters,
I think [inaudible].
>> Jennifer A Nielsen: Which
characters are my favorite?
That's what we're asking?
Is that your question?
About the characters?
Do you know what?
Every character I write
becomes my friend.
So you have friends.
Right? My characters
are my friends.
And they talk to me in my head
which sounds super
crazy, but they do.
And I feel like my characters,
if I saw them on the street,
I would recognize them.
I could never choose a favorite
because I could never
choose a favorite friend.
I love all my characters,
and I want to know them
for a very long time.
Does that help?
Wonderful.
Thank you for your
patience with me.
>> Speaker 9: In your book
"Resistance" how long did
you spend on the research,
and how long did it
take you to write it?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
The research was nearly
a year of research.
And I was writing
at the same time,
but it was very intense
focused research,
and I continued to do it.
It was very important to
me to get this story right.
There are Holocaust
deniers in the world,
and people who say, "No.
That never happened."
And I know if I get a fact
incorrect that somebody can use
that to say, "Well, if
that fact is incorrect,
then it's all fiction."
And so it was very important
to me to get it correct.
So like when I'm describing
a Warsaw ghetto uprising,
there's a point where
Chaya [assumed spelling],
my main character, is
in a building fighting,
and she thinks this might have
been a furniture store once.
That building was a
furniture store once.
Like I get down to that level
of detail because I don't want
to put something in there
that did not happen.
>> Speaker 9: And how
long did it take you
to write it once the --
>> Jennifer A Nielsen: Writing
it was around six months
which is about my average
because I'm super obsessive.
So I just write.
Thank you very much.
>> Speaker 10: Where do you get
your inspiration for your books?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
Inspiration for books
happens this way.
Okay. Everybody can play this
for inspiration for books.
So let's say that right
now all the lights go
out in the whole room.
And they're out for
exactly three seconds,
and the end of three seconds
there are only five people
in this entire room left.
And you are one of them.
All right?
Now where did everybody go?
Why were you kept?
Where is everybody?
Can you find them?
These sorts of questions
happen to me all the time.
So everything and everywhere
I am, I just ask questions.
And then you start
to see story emerge.
So your goal for today,
before you leave this room,
I want you to come
up with an answer.
There's five people left.
You're one of them.
Where did they go, and
why were you left here?
All right?
You answer that,
you've got a story.
That's all I do.
Excellent.
>> Speaker 11: How do
you get your information
on your historical fiction?
>> Jennifer A Nielsen:
Information.
There's two kinds
of ways to research.
The first is primary sources.
That's someone who says,
"It happened to me."
Secondary sources is
a researcher says,
"This happened to her."
I'm not a big fan of
secondary resources
because it passes
through a filter.
Right? I want to
know as much primary.
So I will search out
diaries, interviews,
any first person records.
Photographs become a
first person source
because I'm seeing it as it was.
So my research is always
going to focus first.
That's why this book
is so valuable
because it's first person.
It's her saying,
"This is what we did."
Excellent question.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you all so very much.
I'm going to turn the time
back here, but thank you.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> Nicole Chung: Thank
you all for coming.
If you have any questions
you'd like to ask Jennifer,
her book signing will be
at 3:30 just over there.
There's a sign hanging
in the ceiling saying
"Signing" in case you get lost.
Thank you again.